[Music]
bts channels their inner james bond at
the grammy awards we actually prepared a
new performance yeah never before seen
we're so i
i'm so ready the k-pop superstars opened
their performance with jyn working the
controls while rocking a hand cast due
to injuring his finger last month then
jungkook makes an unforgettable entrance
coming in from the rooftop like a spy
[Applause]
meanwhile j-hope jimin rm and v are
hanging out at various tables in the
audience and v took the opportunity to
chat with olivia rodrigo
[Music]
i feel very lucky to be able to do this
and once jungkook catches the piece of
paper from his bandmate the performance
officially begins
[Applause]
now there's no doubt the mega stars were
the favorites on music's biggest night v
shared a sweet hug with lady gaga jimin
spent time with donatella versace then
the entire band snapped this sweet pick
with chrissy teigen john legend and
their daughter luna bts even had the
chance to reunite with megan the
stallion who collaborated with them on a
remix of butter and speaking of collabs
ahead of the ceremony chloe bailey
revealed to et she would love to work
with the k-pop group
we're talking about collaborations is
there someone that you would love to
collaborate that's here tonight so many
beautiful people that i love bts as for
what's next for the guys here's what
they said on the red carpet do you have
a message you want to wave to the bts
army because they're always watching
j-hope
army stay tuned
stay tuned
[Music]
you